what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and here is everything you need
to know about alden ring going into it
first though there might be some minor
spoilers here and there from trailers
interviews and the network test so if
you want to go in completely fresh i
respect that and feel free to keep tuned
to gamespot for other elder ring content
i'm going to be focusing on gameplay in
this particular video as i don't want
anyone to have to worry about lore or
story spoilers here
eldon ring is the latest game from from
software creators of demon souls dark
souls bloodborne and of course king's
field the game takes the basic action
rpg mechanics of dark souls but
introduces a brand new open world that
completely changes things up similar to
the soulsborne games as of the closed
beta players will be able to choose from
a number of starting classes with stats
they'll be able to upgrade as they level
up allowing for a level of freedom and
creating your own builds the starting
classes thus far are vagabond warrior
hero bandit astrologer prophet samurai
prisoner confessor and wretch with
wretch being the level one build
stats you can choose to upgrade with
each level are vigor mind endurance
strength dexterity intelligence faith
and arcane
this means similar to prior souls born
games you'll have the freedom to choose
between strength quality decks and
varying magic builds or any merger of
those leveling up is only possible after
meeting your first finger maiden melina
once you've met her you'll be able to
level up at any of the game's sites of
grace which act similar to bonfires from
the souls games
at the sights of grace you'll be able to
manage your estus flasks and like dark
souls 3 you'll have a variety of estus
flask types you'll have ones that refill
your hp ones that refill your fp or
focus points that allow you to cast
magic and a brand new flask of wonders
physique which is a customizable estus
flask that will give you varying
attributes depending on what crystal
tiers you equip to it
you'll also be able to upgrade how many
estus flask uses you get by using
special golden seeds if you recall from
the game's trailer there are giant
golden herb trees throughout the game
that are clearly significant there are
also smaller lesser earth trees you can
find throughout the game's map at these
lesser earth trees you'll find special
golden seas which are exactly what you
need to upgrade your estus flask uses
the number of seeds you need will change
as you upgrade your flask and this isn't
the only way to obtain these seeds
additionally you can upgrade the
recovery strength of your estus flasks
back to sites of grace though as the
game is now open world these act like
bonfires from dark souls 2 or 3 and that
you can immediately warp to them once
you've activated them unlike those games
so long as you're not in battle you can
warp to any sight of grace at pretty
much any point in time
the map and world of alden ring is
absolutely massive so these are meant to
not only be a spot of respite but an
important way to quickly travel around
the map
however that means the map could quickly
become overrun with a ridiculous number
of sites of grace every time you enter a
legacy dungeon or smaller dungeon in
order to account for this you'll find
several stakes of america throughout the
game
think of these like mini checkpoints you
can't rest at them like a site of grace
nor can you manage some of your special
equipment here
however if you die you can choose to
return to life at either a nearby state
of america or site of grace this allows
from software to play stakes of america
in ways where you won't have to
tediously backtrack from various sites
of grace if you die and they also won't
need to overpopulate the map with too
many warpable sites of grace
and speaking of death the game works
just like previous soulsborne games and
how it's handled there are no save
points in eldon ring and the game is
consistently auto saving
upon death instead of needing to load a
prior save you'll lose all of your
currency and respawn at your nearest
checkpoint you'll have a chance to
regain this lost currency but should you
die again that currency is permanently
lost in eldon ring this currency is
referred to as runes runes are what
you'll be using to not only purchase
items and weapons in the game but are
also your experience points you'll be
using to level up
on top of purchasing weapons you can use
your runes to upgrade your weapons and
make them more powerful this mechanic is
just like previous games you'll find
various blacksmiths around the lands
between who can upgrade your weapons
with a number of runes and certain rare
upgrade materials
weapon upgrades not only raise their
basic attack power but can also affect
their attribute scaling you can find
these on every weapon under the
attribute scaling section of the menu if
there's a letter next to a stat like a d
next to strength it means that your
weapon has extra bonus damage based on
how good the letter is and how high your
strength stat is
again like prior from software games
various weapons will require certain
attributes in order to be able to use
them in the first place
so that means the best weapon for you
will very much depend on what build
you're using
equip load is also back which means the
heavier the armor and weapons you're
using the slower your character will
move and the less invincibility frames
they'll have when attempting to dodge
away from enemies
new to eldon ring is crafting around the
lands between you'll find various
crafting materials out in the wilderness
and even from slaying various creatures
you'll find roaming about the items you
can craft range from being able to cure
status ailments like poison deposits or
knives you can throw at enemies or even
to crafting special arrows to use with a
bow tated with crafting you'll also be
able to find and or purchase various
cookbooks which will teach the player
how to craft more advanced items
something i've brought up multiple times
at this point is the world map which is
new to alden ring as the game is open
world and the map is so much more
massive than previous souls games from
software has added a map with the
ability to fast travel at certain points
however if you're not the biggest fan of
this edition you don't have to worry too
much as the map is very basic while it
does show the wider world you can use it
to find some points of interest and npcs
may even mark points of interest on the
map the game's smaller dungeons stirring
throughout the world and legacy dungeons
have no maps associated with them so
you'll still have to figure out how to
navigate through those mazes on your own
without the aid of this tool
additionally you don't start off with a
map but rather we'll have to find map
fragments in order to slowly fill it in
yourself
and speaking of dungeons from software
has completely changed how they've
approached the overall map design to
eldon ring in order to create something
open world once you enter the game's
first area in limgrave the map will
immediately open up to you so you won't
have an extremely guided experience and
interwoven map like we've seen in games
like bloodborne or dark souls 1.
however within the lands between you'll
discover both hidden dungeons and legacy
dungeons the hidden dungeons act like
mini dungeons and even though they're
small are little tastes of that classic
from software level design some of these
dungeons are easy to find some are
hidden behind walls you'll need to leap
over and some of them can be found next
to the guidance of statues you'll find
in the world that will help indicate
what direction to go
many of these dungeons are slightly
reminiscent of chalice dungeons from
bloodborne in their scale but unlike
those they're all handcrafted and well
thought out however there are also
larger dungeons you'll find that aren't
legacy dungeons so the size and scope
widely varies
meanwhile the game's legacy dungeons are
similar to major from software areas of
the past
in a way you can think of it like
stumbling upon an area from demon souls
instead of returning to a hub to access
boletaria or separately latria now
you'll be able to travel across an open
world that connects bolotario to latria
or perhaps more on the scale of finding
irithyll the boreal valley from dark
souls 3. the legacy dungeons themselves
are large interwoven and intricately
designed with plenty of verticality and
uniqueness and will give you that
classic from software experience i'm
sure you're craving if you're a fan of
these games
in order to help traverse the world
you'll now have a spectral steed called
torrent who you can summon at any point
in time as long as you're outside of
dungeons and legacy dungeons with a
spectral steed whistle
riding horseback is its own unique
experience in eldon ring all of your
weapons have unique movesets for riding
horseback with some like lance's meant
for this type of combat your horse can
also double jump and utilize spirit
springs to launch up high in the air and
access areas much higher than a double
jump can
there are also bosses you'll find in the
field designed to be fought via
horseback as opposed to on foot while
playing the network test i came across a
tree sentinel boss early on one time i
tackled and defeated him on foot while
another i attempted to fight horseback
while it was certainly possible to do
the fight on foot the battle was far
easier on horseback and this was
definitely meant to be the way to tackle
this particular boss you'll also
encounter a dragon that was shown in the
elder ring trailers and once again this
boss is definitely easier to tackle on
your steed
all of that said as you can't bring your
steed into dungeons this in no way
replaces traditional souls combat but
rather is an additional experience on
top of that classic from software style
gameplay
while the lands between are entirely
connected at least as far as we're
currently aware there is a central hub
similar to firelink shrine majula or the
hunter's dream and you'll find plenty to
do within the hub which is completely
separate from the open world of the game
again as far as we're aware
if you're familiar with prior from
software games you'll have a good grasp
of how combat works it'll have both an
hp and fp meter with fp allowing you to
perform magic and special weapon attacks
you'll also have a stamina meter which
is crucial to these games as you'll need
to wait for it to recharge before you
can perform actions like attacking or
dodging
you'll have four basic sets of moves per
weapon and shield with each weapon you
can use it one-handed with a set of
light attacks or heavier attacks or
choose to dual-wield your weapon for a
separate set of more powerful light and
heavy attacks
you can equip your shields or weapons to
any hand you like meaning if you want
you can wield two weapons at once and
sometimes combine these attacks at the
expense of more defense
each weapon and shield come with the
type of weapon art some of these weapons
are locked per weapon especially when it
comes to unique weapons however you'll
also find many equippable weapon arts as
you play through the game which you'll
be able to equip to non-unique weapons
similar to previous soulsborne games
you'll also be able to parry enemy
attacks opening them up for a much more
powerful repost similarly you can strafe
around your enemies to try and find an
opening to backstab them
new to elden ring are guard counters by
blocking an enemy attack you can
immediately counter with a strong guard
counter that can break the stance of
many stubborn opponents
however it comes with the risk of being
relatively slow so perform these at your
own risk
also new to elden ring are two abilities
carried over from seikiro you'll now be
able to use stealth to sneak around
enemies as well as jump these elements
have worked their way into combat as you
can use stealth to sneak up to enemies
without alerting them to quickly
backstab them or at the very least take
them out before they can call for
reinforcements
meanwhile you can attack while jumping
with these attacks also being a good way
to break enemies guards it also allows
you to reach and attack potential weak
points of certain opponents
outside of melee combat range combat has
returned with various caster builds and
spells you can utilize
to be honest i didn't play around with
these as much as the melee builds so i
don't know quite as much about it but it
seems to act just like prior games with
plenty of amazing spells you'll find
throughout the game
something brand new to elden ring are
spirit ashes you can equip these ashes
in the same slot as your esses flasks
and use them to summon spirits who will
help attack enemies and bosses
in my experience finding spirit ashes
you could equip was like finding any
other weapon or armor with some hidden
away and others available for purchase
from merchants the spirit ashes are
meant to be an additional way players
can tackle challenges and thereby make
the game more accessible to a larger
group of players
while one critique of the game has been
that the spirit ashes make it too easy
especially after people had a chance to
use them in the network test according
to a game informer who played the closed
beta early these summons have been
severely nerfed and hardly do anything
against major bosses
like weapons however you'll be able to
find a special spirit tuner who it seems
like will be able to upgrade the power
of your spirit ashes meaning it's
another thing that from software has
tried to balance into the game with
upgrades
something interesting that was
implemented in the closed beta was that
for defeating certain bosses in this
case market from the trailer and network
test players now receive a talisman slot
talismans act as your special attribute
rings in elden ring as of now it's
unclear how many of these slots you'll
be able to unlock but it's definitely
interesting you currently had to defeat
a boss in order to do so
like demon souls dark souls and
bloodborne alden ring will feature an
always online multiplayer you'll be able
to see bloodstains of other tarnish who
have perished and leave and rate
messages to help other players or try to
get them to waste their time you'll also
be able to invade other players worlds
for pvp meaning as a player who isn't
partaking that you still run the risk of
having your own world invaded by a
hostile player
but you can also summon players to help
you progress and players can be summoned
in to help with pvp
covenants will also be returning
although details on those are currently
scant
miyazaki has stated that he wants the
online multiplayer to be easier to
access than ever before and there are
now summoning pools within eldon ring in
order to make it easier to find players
looking to help or fight
and that's all i have for you today i
hope you enjoyed this i tried my best to
balance revealing important gameplay
details while also not being too
spoilery this is part of a series of
alvin ring content we're making in
preparation for the upcoming release if
you enjoyed this i'd love it if you
checked out my look back at one of my
favorite from software games kings field
and i can't wait to cover more elden
ring and go down this journey with all
you fellow tarnished